على بعد حوالي 40 كيلو مترا من العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه يوجد معمل الاسمنت الضخم
هذا
لا يسمح للسحوفيين بالدخول لذلك تم تصويره
بكاميرا خفيه
قدمنا انفسنا على اساس معارفي احد العمال
هنا اتصل به فقام بادخالنا الى وسط المعمل
مئات العمال من افريقيا واسيا
هنا
يسكنون في هذه المراقد التي يكسو الطين
ارضيتها في الغالب
في هذه الغرفه ذات مساحات 10 امتار مربع
يعيش اربعه عمال في حين ينص القانون
القطري على تخصيص سته امتار مربع لكل عامل
تنتشر الخرسانه وغبارها في كل زاويه
يدخل الغبار من هنا اذا لم نضع الاغطيه
سيكتسي كل شيء بالبيض غدا صرت اتالم كثيرا
في صدر منذ بدات العمل هنا هل تعتقد ان
ذلك بسبب الغبار نعم لانني لم اكن اعاني
من قبله
يتقاضى هذا العامل قرابه 1000 يورو شهريا
مقابل العمل لسبعين ساعه في الاسبوع دون
ان يرتاح ولو اليوم واحد قبل عامين تعرض
لحادث اثناء العمل فكاد ان يفقد سقه تبين
لنا فيما بعد ان معمل الاسمنت القطريه
تعامل مع مجموعتين فرنسيه تدران مشروع
البناء في قطر
هل تعلم هذه المجموعه
عن الامر
في حين اكدت مجموعه فانسي ان القضاء
الفرنسي استدعى شركتها الفرعيه من اجل
النظر في احتمال توجيه تهمه اليها في اطار
تحقيق حول ظروف العمل بوشات البناء في قطر